how did you feel about Donald Trump
having dinner with Kanye West and the
white supremacist Nick Fuentes two
people who spewed a lot of anticipation
I thought it was horrible and I said so
I think it's a big mistake it's wrong
it's wrong from every point of view how
damaging is it when someone with Kanye
West's following suddenly seems to go
Rogue anti-semitic in the way that he
did
my father was a great historian and a
historian of anti-Semitism it goes back
about 2500 years as a sort of a doctrine
that keeps changing
but basically people say there's trouble
in the world I want to blame the Jews we
have a setback here or a setback there
blame the Jews the Communists say the
Jews are the capitalists the capitalists
say the Jews are the Communists blame
the Jews so you know that's a
deep-seated pattern it should not be
continents it should not be accepted it
should be rebuked and condemned and
that's what I do and I don't care
I don't care where it comes from or from
whom